wait a minute hold up go back
oh my god
the chase sequence i'm just not buying
it once
i hate the cg punch zoom i hate that you
hate the cg i hate cg punch zooms
they're not necessary
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video stick around at the end to see how
you can get three months free of
membership hey guys welcome to visual
effects artists react and today is oh
man what a special day not only do we
have clint but today oh we are served up
with some of the finest visual effects
you have ever seen i'm so excited to see
it clint what are these clips we're
going to see we're going to see some
janky
some real janky v effects wait really
this is a janky episode i got some janky
vfx for you where is this jank what's
the source of this jam all right look
they've been making resident evil movies
for far too long resident evil resident
evil has brought me so much joy but this
latest movie is is far beyond like it
just falls off i'm gonna try my best to
focus on just the effects you can still
enjoy bad things no it's not one of
those oh
it's not even one this is just like one
of those sad
bad ones
[Music]
before we watch welcome to new raccoon
city let's take a peek at welcome to
raccoon city
that punch-out camera shake
it feels like they took a bunch of super
large-scale explosions that are normally
played at slower speed because they're
supposed to be
larger and in the background but it's in
the foreground it should be moving way
faster it's like they put like three
20-foot explosions in the scene and
they're all like 10 feet tall exactly i
don't know if it's a slow-mo shot or if
it's actual full speed well it's slow
because it's like halfway it's big
explosions made small so they act really
slow
right so it makes it feel slow motion
yeah so normally when you're compositing
fire elements like this you got to make
sure that the speed of the fire element
is scaled to the scene you can cheat it
a little bit but you can't cheat it a
lot it's all about the speed of the
flames like how fast is the turbulence
going how fast are they rising like
temperature all that crap you could
technically make like a torch fire a
little bit bigger you might even be able
to turn it into candlelight if you did
some tricks but you can't make it five
feet tall yeah general rule of thumb is
that the smaller an explosion element is
the faster it needs to be run so if
you're shrinking down something increase
the speed of it as well and in this case
they were pressed for time as usually
always r as a vfx artist and you could
either simulate an explosion where you
would probably get more accurate results
that's a whole other thing in this case
they're using stock footage comp over
this truck and when you're pulling super
large scale explosions and scaling them
down to fit your scene you really gotta
be aware of the speed at which those
explosions are moving
that's the most casual firewall was that
an actual that was obvious obviously
there was cg fire on that but was there
a basis of like an actual fire suit yeah
i think that's 100 cg bro it was
definitely cg we're looking at i'm just
curious if there's real fire underneath
it you know i think the dude is cg yeah
dude i think the whole dude is cg and
the reason they're not flailing is
because you know how difficult it's
gonna be to comp 2d fire elements onto
this so they're like just be as still as
possible and give me this so we can make
our job as easy as possible with the
fire i don't know i'm knowing nothing
about this it feels like if there's some
zombie dude coming in it's like that
feels like a directing note to me you
are casual as you're burning you've done
that before
casually not that casually oh yeah i'm
ready man feel safe i'm ready
well the idea is that like if you're
standing there the fire will be in your
face in your nose in your eyes if you're
moving forward it'll be behind you so
this just looks like the full back
whereas see how it's illuminating you
though it is like your clothing is being
lit
so we can safely say what they're doing
is they have a guy walk through a dark
room and then they slash cg fire all
over him and then they hit render and
then they move on this is pretty good
reference though like look at the
exposure of the actual fire itself it's
mostly clipping you know like all the
fire the white hot in the middle like
that's just too bright for the sensor
and the exposure and we're starting to
get some of that detail back at the
edges of the fire where it's starting to
cool off you could drop the exposure and
get more detail in the fire
but then the body would be more dark
right exactly yeah you'd lose the
background too it's definitely some
visual effects fire in the resident evil
shot we're not saying it's practical or
digital here it's just is it practical
foundation with a digital top or is it
completely digital they probably had a
real guy do the walk but they replaced
them with the 3d model effectively and
that's really all we're seeing at this
point is just like
the the stuff they tracked on to him
everything has like a certain speed you
know movement to it and the stuff on the
back is like turbo you know makes me
feel like they're combining a full body
simulation with the fire yeah and then
using some elements to like amp it up
basically yeah i think you're right sam
i think there is a basis foundation of a
simulated fire with a bunch of big
larger scale high flame elements up at
the top especially around like his
shoulder blades up
here we go we finally got it we finally
got what we were waiting for it looks
like doom like really good doom in-game
footage like cut scene footage
that's wait a minute
wait a minute hold up go back
oh my god so dumb that's just like the
the shot is basically informing me i'm
about to see a rocket go down the dude's
mouth and then it immediately cuts to an
explosion with the dude in the
foreground tumbling away from it so the
tell for me is the directionality of the
turbulence in a thing like this it's
very like it's almost kind of creamy
yeah if that makes sense yeah and
when you simulate an explosion you
basically have a bunch of little blocks
in a 3d scene and those blocks contain
information like temperature pressure
direction of forces these are voxels
you're talking about yeah i'm talking
about voxels yeah and so the way those
forces can go between the voxels ends up
being very just like left right up down
and that's just how voxels work it's
very just going in like these 90 degree
angles as opposed to diagonally it's
something i see in every single sort of
smoke simulation it's hard to get around
especially in something kind of small
and turbulent like this but once the
explosion resolves and you get the nice
smoke
that usually looks really nice but we're
talking about the beginning of an
explosion here which i think is the
hardest part to do
so they're they're like blocking out the
beginning part of the explosion with a
bright white light which is probably you
know the way to go you hide the jankiest
parts of the beginning of that explosion
and it probably would happen in real
life where there's a bright flash of
light it's always about how would you do
this in real life if you're gonna have
let's say have a practical monster and
you want a big practical rocket blast on
it it's like what is that actually going
to look like and how do you recreate
that versus here which is basically they
say all right uh fire simulation go boop
element done rendered fire doesn't spawn
out of nothingness what's our charge
what's our detonation device gonna look
like what's creating that initial blast
there's all these elements here not to
mention it's a rocket maybe it's more
concussive maybe there's more sparks
where's the shrapnel like what are these
additional elements that are exploding
that give us context instead of this
ethereal fire that's spawned out of
nothingness you know because
no explosion is just fire spawned out of
nothingness these it's like gasoline of
in this case that's that would be
gasoline maybe even they could do a
propane kind of like charge or something
like that
a rocket launcher
found in first class
we don't need to spend any more time on
this movie we can move on
i hate the cg punch zoom i hate that you
hate the cg i hate cg punch zooms
they're not necessary what about when
it's in outer space you gotta really
crop in no did you see one single punch
zoom in this entire sequence up until
the point you got cg no not at all we
need to spice it up with some sort of
punchiness
punch it up with a punch zoom bunch it
up no
like the cg looks great it's fine it
looks great yeah i actually thought the
cg looked great too the worm looks
pretty good because for starters it's
well rendered the scene has overcast
lighting and that lends itself to better
renders because renders typically look
pretty good with a very top-down even
softbox light if you want something to
look good put a giant even softbox above
your render like the dark knight garage
you know freaking unbox therapy garage
at the same time too it's like an
insanely render intensive lighting
environment to have a huge softbox like
this because to calculate that type of
render we're dealing with like 180
degrees of like a hemisphere of just
like light angles hitting it on every
like direction and so there's tons of
bounces and stuff like that it looks
really nice because it's a very like
naturalistic approach to lighting
there's like some good subsurface
scattering going on on the top of it the
shading and ambient occlusion is nice
like i don't know like the animation
it's all jiggly it's well designed but
there are three things that make the
compositing of this render look flawless
to me one the lighting matches perfectly
the contrast matches perfectly and the
saturation of the colors match perfectly
interesting choice making it look like
there's graffiti on this bug it's very
colorful and there's a lot of real
graffiti in the shot there's a bunch of
blues and oranges and reds the bug also
has those oranges and blues and reds and
they look like they belong together they
match the dark value on the underside of
the bug matches the dark values of the
underside of the car the underside of
the scaffolding yeah the highlights are
catching perfectly the highlights on the
back of the bug match perfectly to the
highlights up in the sky also they're
doing a great job of comping in that red
mist earlier in the foreground between
the bug and the camera and they're
hiding the ground interaction that the
bug has which is a great move if your
ground doesn't look entirely 100 solid
and it's contact with the ground then
you just put a little bit of red mist
there solid yeah good worm effects not
bad
hey guys quick interruption to just let
you know that the second episode of our
netflix show punch for punch just
dropped on their youtube channel i
recommend going to check it out this one
is all about stunt driving and how it
gets done in the movies we worked with
real stunt drivers and gee even learned
how to pull off some complicated tricks
that expert stunt drivers use anyway i
just want to let you know still watching
netflix is the youtube channel that it's
on check it out enjoy the rest of this
episode oh this is gonna be crazy
[Music]
triceratops for those of you who don't
know anything about prehistoric planet
if you've ever heard of the show planet
earth it's literally the same show but
instead of about animals it's about
dinosaurs every time we see a dinosaur
in jurassic park it's doing something
crazy and wacky for the sake of a scene
or some you know someone's writing a
scene where dinosaurs dinosaur supposed
to do something here versus this which
is they just real life they're going all
right how do these creatures actually
act what is our best like take on
depicting the actions and the mind of
these creatures it is all about how
you're trying to get an accurate look at
how these creatures act
[Music]
[Laughter]
look at these little little guys wow
dude i can feel like i can take my
fingernails and go along its skin and go
so a scene like this the hard part is
the animation and the modeling once you
have that done it's now down to
rendering you gotta light the scene and
render it and that for a situation like
this
pretty straightforward i gotta be honest
you have the footage of the background
you have like this nice open area so you
have a bunch of trees in the back and
there's not really anything in the
center so the lighting setup i imagine
is simply setting up a sun source and
then a bunch of gobos blocking the light
like the trees would what's a gobo wren
is a shaped light pattern that is either
blocking the light or projecting a
pattern of light into a scene such as
the dappled tree lighting that we're
seeing here as these dinosaurs are
walking forward they're walking in and
out of shades and light but instead of
modeling all of the trees around it you
just put a texture of like a bunch of
leaves on a plane and you put it up out
of view and you get the shadows from
those leaves down on the dinosaur it's a
very efficient way to get very accurate
lighting and no one can ever tell but in
this case
we're gobowing the sun so
so the light source is at an infinite
distance
the light is parallel and so i imagine
what they did for the sequence is they
probably have like these dinosaurs that
are like this tall and they put the
gobos maybe like two or three times
higher than their heads
just to simulate the the canopy of the
forest
so what makes a good dinosaur 3d model
enough polygons high resolution
texture detail because look at them they
got freaking lizard skin and like
reptile skin it's not just scales it's
like a thick knobbly skin
and so you just got to have a lot of
detail there and of course a lot of
color variation it's a high-res model
but it's also use of a normal map and
probably a displacement map that
actually pushes the geometry for real
whereas the bump and the normal map
cheat detail and they're probably using
all of that to get these beautiful
results a normal map is just telling it
that the light is going this way but a
displacement map is actually displacing
the geometry at a sub polygon level you
can see it if you were to put a rocky
normal map on a sphere look at the edge
of that sphere it's going to be
perfectly smooth but if you put a
displacement map of the same type of
texture on a sphere you're looking at
the edge of it and it will be bumpy
because it's actually displacing it the
modeling of these dinosaurs they're
usually using a program like zbrush or
maybe mudbox to actually sculpt it like
you would out of clay and they're
putting huge amounts of detail into
every square inch of these dinosaurs and
so they end up with these massively huge
files for every single dinosaur but then
all of that detail gets baked down into
image textures like normal maps and
displacement maps so that the geometry
can then be simplified so that it can be
simulated it's easy to think about
visual effects and go oh there's no
creative tricks going on anymore you
know back in the day when it was all
practical effects you know they had to
come up with such like creative
solutions to get a shot done but when
you look at these dinosaurs like there's
still
a lot of tricks that are happening to
get this level of detail so all these
mapping
techniques are are the trick so to speak
to get
all the cool moving skin and all that
stuff dynamic but still then have those
close-ups where it's just like so
incredibly high detailed but it looks 3d
still it's like a combination of so many
things it's like okay excellent creature
design team we're doing the bone
structure we're doing the muscle
structure we're making a unique like
dinosaur like skin
like system that's totally different
from like mammals animations is it
raptors chasing a motorcycle no like
it's all it's so instantly it's gonna
look more realistic because you're not
putting them in unrealistic situations
none of these sort of stylistic edge
lights on the backs of velociraptors no
no more leaping raptors you know jumping
at your car or landing on the roof of
your truck
so
if we were to like pause on any of these
shots it looks composited well into the
shot yeah it's hard to tell because
everything's moving so fast and so
blurry and it's just like i can tell
there's a dinosaur generally chasing
chris pratt on a bike i mean how much of
a gripe do you guys have with the way
the raptors run in this new jurassic
park look i never see them act like
dinosaurs you know what i'm saying or
like i don't ever see them acting like
animals they're like missiles
yeah yeah they're always got freaking
missile lock on it's one of those
sequences that looks super fun on paper
it's like imagine a motorcycle sequence
but instead of motorbikes it's raptors
it's like yeah and then like we're
seeing and it's like i'm just not buying
it once like the entire sequence i'm
just like i don't i'm not i'm not
suspending my disbelief here and that's
my problem with it and that i don't know
if that's the visual effects problem
that's making me not suspend my
disbelief or if it's just the context
and the situation it's totally the
context and i think it's a great time to
talk about it you know like we're not we
don't need to talk about criticizing
direction or writing and stuff but like
right now we have prehistoric planet
which really goes hard into
trying to show these as real creatures
and then we have this here if you're
just watching jurassic park and jurassic
world movies and that's your dinosaur
content like sure that's fine but the
moment you start to actually get that
other side of the spectrum you can see
what's really lacking when it comes to
everything from like how they're being
filmed to like the design and the
modeling the creature direction all that
stuff because like once you get that
taste of going okay let's imagine they
are creatures that are not intelligent
you know they have tiny brains or you
know very low powered lizard brains you
know like once you get that taste and
come back to this
now you're like wait a second like i
want more now like i want i need more
than this yeah if i want to be
entertained by this
no
here it matches up pretty well the color
is pretty good the light source is
coming from the correct direction like
it's not wrong so to speak it just looks
a little extra it's produced first off
it's the design like yeah okay they're
like let's make them look evil and angry
and super crazy and like oh they're
villains i feel like the first jurassic
park is super scary because they're
treating them like animals you know
they're huge creatures and they're
unpredictable and they're carnivores
whereas here it's like you just can't
shake the feeling that like these
dinosaurs are like acting you know and
once again it's not like a flaw so to
speak this is like we're talking about
like a total like direction here this is
intentional when you start to go down
that path of like not having a creature
or an animal
act like itself you show your cards
there you're like okay this is cg it's
fake you need subtlety and you need some
realism and yeah and no one's buying
this because it's too maxed and that the
problem that's stemming from that is
that is now hurting the actual effects
themselves because people aren't buying
the situation and they're blaming it on
the vfx exactly because like yeah the
rendering is great lighting's great
awesome shaders look at that awesome
eyeball subsurface scattering on the
gums and tongue and lips and stuff there
cool teeth great displacement mask
scaling hyper detailed texture great
shot well composited well tracked
it's well animated however at the same
time it's like we're forgetting it's a
this is a lizard
this is like this is part of a much
larger conversation and i'd love to see
that conversation down in the comments
below let's talk about it like where is
too much when it comes to creating
creatures
hi brandi o'daniel here and i used to be
so stressed wondering how i was going to
keep my internet data safe and secure
but courtesy of today's sponsor
expressvpn life's so much better now i
can protect my internet data through and
through on any device however i access
the internet just by using expressvpn
you see if you don't know expressvpn
works by first and foremost giving your
data an additional layer of encryption
as it's out on the open internet this
means it's less susceptible to being
stolen by third-party hackers or
third-party advertisers who want to
steal and sell your data who wants that
nobody wants that the best part about
expressvpn is that it gives you access
to content that might not be available
in your country or region for example
we're here in the united states we can't
access the entire studio ghibli library
on netflix but if we use a vpn which
will tell the internet that we're
accessing a platform like netflix from
an entirely different location we can
then get access to that entire library
and now we love expressvpn here at
corridor digital but if you don't
believe me just know this they've been
rated number one by forbes and tech
radar and they've got servers in over 94
countries meaning that they're one of
the fastest vpn services out there you
can use them on any device phone tablet
laptop pc tv
smart fridge and if you guys are
interested in getting access to content
that might not be available to you and
protecting your internet data as it's
out on the open internet click the link
in the description below or go to
expressvpn.com
corridor crew where you can find out how
to get three months free
you need me
i'll be in the water
[Music]
what an episode that was a fun one yeah
a lot a lot of speculation there you
know like there's not a ton of
behind-the-scenes material for some of
this stuff right now but it's it's good
to look at it because it's all
fresh and it's brand new this is like
cutting edge stuff all the jurassic
world stuff all this prehistoric planet
stuff like this is the top of the line
stuff when it comes to creature visual
effects right now so i think it's it's
super important to be able to play and
react and watch the stuff even when the
information about how it's made isn't
out there yet still a lot we can garner
from it you know everything from you
know context animation the research that
goes into how these creatures behave and
react and all this stuff like there is
knowledge out there that we can still
apply to it yeah i really enjoyed going
through these clips so thanks for
watching this is a really fun one we
will see you next week
[Music]